i'm joshua fidel i'll be doing my
lecture on
insane in the end game um
and it'll be hopefully an interactive
lecture where i can ask you guys
questions you can make suggestions
uh i'll be looking at the uh youtube
um so hey sedan
how's it going uh regular guest to my
own streams
um in any case uh welcome everyone so
today i wanted to go over
some complex end games i felt simply do
simple end games when the
it's insane in the end game but uh so i
want to go over some complex end games
these are these are the end games i've
lectured on before and are
some favorites of mine to work with just
because there are lots of complexities
and
they're just really fun to go over they
show lots of concepts
so the first one is
a from carlson adams from the
baku fide grand prix in 2008
so this was when carlson was extremely
strong high 2700 player not world
champion yet
but already a fantastic technical player
against michael adams who
was britain's number one and obviously
very strong player himself
uh and in this game carlson was white
and already it's kind of an interesting
position really really complex lots of
things going on here um
so i would say that at the moment uh
white's down the exchange
and for absolutely nothing like there's
no pawn even
but i would say that white has a lot to
offer for that exchange white has a
dominating knight on d4 which looks
really nice
beautiful bishops i would say black has
more weaknesses the pawn on d5 is a bit
weak
if it falls the pawn on b7 would also be
weak the king on e7 is not exactly
perfect so there are lots of things that
are not great about black's position and
that are really nice about white's
position and uh
again i mean the to get to fully grasp
like how an exchange sack affects the
position is really difficult
but it's still not easy white black's
the only one with open file and does
have the extra exchange so it seems
likely to be able to keep it
but it's a tricky position to figure out
how to proceed and one of the tricky
things
is to figure out exactly what you want
to do with your pieces because a lot of
the times improving your pieces to the
maximum
is really important so i guess
the first question i'll ask you guys is
as white what piece do you think
needs to be improved the most and how
would you improve it
so again i'm looking at the youtube chat
so if you have suggestions definitely
make it there
so hector lopez recommends g2 to g4
um and this would be a move that makes a
lot of sense
so recommending this move but
the drawback to this and the idea is you
kick the rook from the square right
and you're going to try to take this
pawn i'm assuming the drawback to this
move is that there's rook
h2 check and then your bishop falls on
b2
so i would say that while
that's a rather normal idea to try to
play g4 it makes sense positionally this
rook h2 check idea is really annoying
so you probably want to find something
else
yeah i mean a move like b5 is definitely
one to be considered
uh you have to be careful opening up the
position too much because sometimes that
favors the rooks
and after a move like b5 b5 is
definitely a very interesting move here
uh maybe black could try something like
i mean let's see so
let's say b5 that was not what he played
in the game maybe a move like knight e5
is interesting so i'm trying to fork you
with knight d3 check
if you take on a6 i'll simply take back
uh the problem you have here is that
if you allow if you look the board
becomes too open
sometimes it can be kind of annoying
because the rooks will become very
strong you can try bishop a3 but
probably i can sidestep with the king
i'm not exactly sure what's going on
here to be perfectly honest it's a
really crazy position but b5 is
definitely a very sensible move
but in this position carlson instead
decided to simply improve a piece not to
try to initiate any kind of
complications
so bishop c2 definitely looks like it
improves the bishop but really you're
trying to target this pawn on d5
and that's kind of the key here you have
to ask yourself what is the main
weakness black has and to me it's that
pawn on d5
so what carlson's move does is
it attempts to really go after
and you know prove that black really
does have this
weakness so rook d1 is a nice uh idea to
do that as well
but it's a bit slow right you play rook
d1 you have to watch out for a5 type
moves all the time a5a4 maybe trying to
break up your pawns
so carlson tries to do something a bit
faster
uh so someone recommended e4 but again
you have to the problem with e4 is
you're actually trading off your
opponent's weakness
and although it makes sense because the
king on e7 is quite weak so maybe after
like if for example if if i go for e4
takes
rookie one for instance maybe the king
will have to move back to f8 or
something
but the fact is that you are trading off
a big weakness that your opponent has
right
so you have to be a little bit cautious
with that
so rook a5 again looks nice but the
problem is the pawn on c5 kind of blocks
you so i'd say your rook on a5 is a
little out of play there
um so the reason this is hard i think
for you guys
because i do think his move is probably
the best move almost for sure
uh not just for positional reasons but
for concrete reasons as well
the reason why this is so hard is
because probably when you're looking at
this position you don't think of this
piece as misplaced
but it actually is and that piece
believe it or not is the knight on d4
the 994 it's one of those things that
people kind of get
awestruck by nights like this they're
like oh man it's such a beautiful night
it does so much
and the fact is the net on d4 is good
but it doesn't really attack anything
and sometimes it's very important
to ask yourself okay is this piece
really good
can i do more with it and the fact is
the nanod4 can actually do a lot more
somewhere else so i see king g1 and g4
mentioned again playing for g4 makes
sense but
with the king on f2 is just too weak and
if king ji won i can probably play for
example
rook h8 threatening rook h1 and i think
this is actually a step in the wrong
direction for you
so i would recommend something else
so once again i think you actually have
to improve this knight on
d4 so b5 was already suggested which
again i i don't think is a bad move i
think it's quite promising
uh but he chooses to go for something
else king lord pie very nice
so knight e2 and again it looks weird at
first right because the knight on d4
looks so pretty
but the fact is that the knight going to
f4 is actually going to be even stronger
because it hits the rook it hits the
pawn on d5 if a knight lands on d5 the
black king's gonna be unhappy
and playing g5 cuts off the rook so that
then bishop takes d5 or some simple move
like that is just going to be very
strong
so believe it or not this very simple
move almost makes black's position
entirely fall apart
so 92 to f4 is like a really really nice
maneuver
and it's part of it's one of the things
that you know
it's a very advanced maneuver not
because it's so hard to see by itself
but because
it's so easy to forget that the knight
on d4 can be improved even though it's
such a nice piece
so yeah knight f4 coming and the fact is
that after knight f4 black already has
some issues here
because the rook and pawn are forked and
you can retreat along the h file but
then i can simply take on d5 and i have
a really nice position
so for example if the rook goes back i
can take on d5
take with the bishop and even though
i've only won a pawn and i'm still
down a pawn for an exchange technically
the two bishops are really powerful
and i would say that this pawn on b5
is a very big weakness here so this is
the kind of position where i think that
white would
enjoy a very nice advantage so adams
decides instead
to try to hold on to the pawn to try to
be a little greedier basically saying
that even though the rook on g5 looks
out of play and i think it is
holding onto the d-pawn is important
because it keeps white's pieces at bay
uh if black gets to hold on to that
d-pawn it's much harder for white to
crash through
so carlson though decides that it's
extremely important here
to make sure he crashes through with his
pieces
and once again he finds a really really
nice idea for white
um ibrahim taking the taking with the
bishop's also possible
um but the drawback to that would be if
i play bishop takes knight takes and
move my king
you've checked me and your knight on d5
is very good but it doesn't attack as
much
i would say even though the nano d5
looks nice i think a bishop there would
be
more useful as far as attacking pieces
because the pawn on b7 is such a
weakness and the bishop on b5 attacks it
while the knight doesn't so that would
be kind of my answer to that
although you might be right that taking
with the bishop is also promising
so rook d1 again is again i would call
it a slower move you're attacking the
pawn
but let's say you play rook d1
and i play rook d8 it's a little unclear
to me how you're gonna
continue attacking because i'm pretty
well defended here e4 i think i can take
it
takes on f7 i can take here so what i'm
talking about is this
so you can't quite go for these tactics
taking on f7 leads to ticks on d1
um if you take on d8 i can take with the
knight of course to not
drop a piece and i think i'm doing fine
so somehow this kind of idea just
doesn't work and obviously you're not
going to play e4 but if you don't play
e4 it's very hard to attack the d5 pawn
i would say that white still has great
compensation
don't get me wrong because black can't
really do that much
but the fact is that you don't really
have a clear way to improve your
position
so rook d1 again is one of those moves
where i think it looks really nice
but it's just not well suited to the
position
so the belgica i see a really nice
suggestion and that is for b5 which is
what was played in the game
which is a really nice move so one of
the trickiest things
to do in chess i would say is to know
when to kind of go for a move like b5
when to strike
and when to improve a piece so the
general rule i use
is i ask myself can my opponent improve
their pieces better than i can
so if we take our initial position here
i would say we still have pieces to
improve we have a knight to improve
in particular bringing it to f4 we still
have a lot of improvements we can make
and i would say that when that's the
case oftentimes you'd rather improve
than to simply like try to lash out with
a pawn move
whereas when we take this position we've
already kind of improved our pieces to
the max our pieces are all really nice
the rook on g5 is a little bit odd but
black will improve
if given time so this is the kind of
position we're playing quickly i think
makes a lot more sense so
yeah b5 i think is a really nice move
and someone's asking won't we end up
with a weak maybe isolated c pawn and
that's absolutely correct
uh but this is something i actually
talked about
uh earlier today i think when i did my
twitch stream uh
on uh for the club where i was talking
about how
um and actually maybe it was even in a
lecture earlier where i said
uh they're blurring together at the
moment um
where i talked about how gms in general
tend to
prioritize peace play more than other
players
and pawn structure and stuff like that
actually less even though it sounds
weird you think of
you know ah like you know gm is all
about like nuanced play and stuff like
that and it's true but the fact is that
pawn structure matters to an extent but
the fact is that maximizing your pieces
being able to create threats
tends to matter more than how your pawns
look so after bishop takes b5 which of
course is forced you can't really
retreat
and a takes b5 of course runs into rook
takes a8 which would just
be very bad so the bishop has to take
knight takes d5
and you can see how the bishop the two
bishops your knight on d5
black's just getting attacked horribly
here and even though it's an end game
this is really about
active piece play and about initiative
and you'll find that end games are like
this a lot more than you'd think
so after a knight takes d5 check i think
that
it's already black has to be very
careful just to stay in the game
so maybe the best option was to play
rook takes d5
with the idea that you sack the exchange
back
and then activate your rook so the idea
is that if white tries to take this pawn
kind of carelessly you have this check
and winning a piece
so probably white should play a move
like e4 to consolidate the bishop
but maybe now you can even play a move
like rook d7 just trying to
solidify and while i definitely think
white's better even though it's even
material the two bishops are really
powerful here
but i would say that black's not like
lost by any means and i think that black
could fight on here pretty well
but black instead decided to try to be a
little bit uh i don't know if i want to
say greedier but trying to
sack the exchange back at a more
opportune moment and played king of
king f8 so the question is how to
continue the initiative here is white
what do you guys think
so notice how the 95 is very powerful
but the reason why it's so powerful is
because it's backed up by the two
bishops and by other pieces
just by itself the knight is often not
so great it needs
friends you know
so how to continue now what do you guys
think
is the point of the endgame just to
queen upon i would say no um
queening upon is often how you'll win an
end game but a lot of the times
especially when there are lots of pieces
on the board like there are now
there's a lot of dynamics that come way
before that and a lot of end games don't
even come to someone queening upon
often there's a resignation or someone's
kind of dead lost way before then
um so i wouldn't say that it's all about
queening pawns but queenie ponds becomes
a lot more significant in that game
that's for sure
so knight c7 you guys spot it right away
so yeah knight p4 doesn't quite do as
much but knight c7 and again
this is something that i think it's a
basic thing that it but it's forgotten
by lots of people
which is that you want to look at the
moves that threaten your opponent first
always
and it doesn't matter whether it's a
middle game or an end game or an opening
knight c7 immediately attacks a rook
and threatens knight e6 which in turn
forks the two pieces
so you always want to look for attacking
moves before you look at retreating
moves right
or building moves so attacking moves
always come first
and it's a good habit to get into so
rook d8
was played so of course adam saw that he
was going to get forked to
to death with 96 check here but the fact
is that he really didn't have a choice
at this point so i think he was just
trying to sack the exchange back
in a more favorable manner he plays king
yate
and this is the kind of move which i
really like i don't know that it's
necessarily clearly the best but i
really like
kind of what this move signifies the
kind of approach that carlson takes here
so this is white to move what would you
guys do
so knight takes d8 of course is a
perfectly good move there's nothing
wrong with taking that
that rook um taking the rook on g5 i
wouldn't recommend because it allows
rook d2 check which i think
is not a complication you really need or
want
um but taking the rook on d8 is
perfectly fine there's nothing wrong
with taking that rook
but i really like kind of the approach
he takes here
so bishop f6 gf6 i'm not sure how you're
helping your position unfortunately i
think you're giving away a bishop
and it's okay guys remember like uh
we've all suggested bad moves in our
lifetime i have to remind people
this when i do streams a lot that people
are hesitant to suggest moves and it's
like
i've suggested and played way more bad
moves than most people will in a
lifetime you know it's
it's uh it's quite okay so you know if
you think you have a good idea
then definitely say it and if you're
wrong it's not a big deal right
um but it's definitely a good habit to
try to think your idea through a little
bit more right like
don't just like if you see an attacking
move don't just be like well that has to
be good you know
uh knight g7 again you're you're giving
away too many pieces because knight g7
rook g7 bishop f6
you're forking the rooks but you're
already forking the rooks right
and you're giving away a night in the
process so um
yeah so what i'm talking about is like
trying to do this is a really cool idea
but let's say i do something like this
and for example
actually that's a bad move because i'm
allowing you to take here which is not
what i should be doing
but let's say in this position i play
like rook h7 right
so now my rook's threatening to move and
if you take it i take back with
say a knight now all of a sudden you
have these three pawns but i have an
extra piece
and the reason i have an extra piece is
because you kind of gave it away on g7
so i would say that
even though it's kind of an exciting
move it
you don't really get enough for two
pawns i'd say a piece for two pawns is
not enough
knight c7 check is possible but then
let's say i moved back maybe even back
to ef8 maybe back to e7 i don't know
the problem is now rook d2 check is a
serious threat and the knight on c7
doesn't actually do that much
so that's not exactly a move i would uh
i would think about too much
i gave it away with my move i'm sorry
yeah this is a tricky one he played
bishop d4
and again this is the kind of move which
is like i think of
like an iconic carlson move but really
like karpov kind of played rooms like
this too
but the idea is that it basically says
look
you can't save a rook so i'm not in a
rush to take one i'm simply going to
consolidate my pieces and the bishop on
d4 cuts off the rook on d8
and i know you could be thinking well
you could have just taken the rook which
is true
but it keeps the rook cut off it guards
both the c pawn and the e pawn
and it asks black what they're doing
because it's not so easy to actually
save these rooks the rook on g5 can't
really move anywhere great
because the g7 pawn hangs as well in a
lot of cases
and taking the bishop doesn't really
help your cause because if you take and
i take with the e pawn all of a sudden
this rook on g5 is still horrible and
it's probably gonna be lost
so it's a really cool move just in that
it's basically
like look i'm just going to improve my
pieces and let you get out of the fork
you know i'm not going to make your life
easier by just taking a rook
so this is the kind of thing that again
carlson is really good and you can
really learn from um
and in complex endings this is the kind
of move that happens a lot where you're
basically like
you know what i'm going to just build my
position even though i could take
something because oftentimes the tension
favors you and in this case having that
net on e6 making black uncomfortable
there's no reason to disrupt that
tension because it makes it harder for
black not for white in my opinion
and i would say this is something again
that you'll notice gm's in general but
particularly carlson and
really great technical players like to
do they like to make the tension
uncomfortable for you so that you're the
one who flinches first
um but just in general bishop d2 is just
a really nice improving move
so adams plays bishop d7 to basically
say look buddy you're gonna take one of
my rooks
so he obliges
takes on d8 knight takes d8 you have to
take with the knight because otherwise
your knight on f7 will hang
and he improves the rook rook h1
e4 so again just improving in the center
knight e6 bishop back to e3
rook e5 so again this rook that
you know adamus played rook g5 which was
quite sensible trying to keep
a little bit like trying to hold on to
the d5 pawn but the fact is that this
rook is now causing him all sorts of
problems
so rook h7
bishop c2 so the idea is that he wants
to play f4
f4 so probably actually adam should have
sacked an exchange with rook takes e4
and here i actually think that there are
some drawing chances because you can
grab this exchange but the bishop on c6
the net on e6 it's at least relatively
solid
so i definitely think that black should
be doing quite
like white should be doing well here
obviously white's up in the exchange
it's not enough compensation but
it definitely would be at least
challenging to win just because you're
covering the b7 weakness
and it's very difficult to break down
that kind of fortress sometimes
so i think sacking the exchange this way
would have been better he chose bishop
takes e4
and he plays rook h8 check to get to
make sure the rook's not hanging
here and then this was a really really
nice move
so i'm gonna have you guys find it
and yesterday i would say that uh
there's definitely
peace domination is a good way to
describe it you just have really great
pieces
uh and it makes it very difficult
um so what would you do as white here
again this is the kind of position where
accuracy
is paramount because sometimes one
inaccurate move will make the win
so much harder for you
um and these are the kind of positions
where i think that people get
too complacent and they just play try to
play a quick move and oftentimes you
play a quick move and then
all of a sudden the easy win that you
had or the really nice position can kind
of get worse
so i see a bunch of suggestions for c6
that's an interesting move
uh i guess my main complaint with it
would be what happens if i simply take
this
if i take with the bishop then of course
you're taking my rook but what happens
if i just take the pawn
because the problem now is if you take
my rook and i take here you've
simplified the game yes i have two weak
pawns here
but i feel like you're only gonna have
probably gonna have to take on f6 i'll
take back the only have one pawn left
in an exchange up position and i'd say
that even if you win both
my pawns and i don't think you will be
able to
i don't think this is going to be so
clear
so i really really don't care for this
move c6
uh i see a suggestion for rook b8 and
this is indeed the correct move
very nice so the idea of this move
is that if the bishop takes on c2
you don't have to take the rook right
away you throw in a little inner mezzo
check
and this is just deadly because now
you're going to take the rook and the c
pawn is going to be an enormous strength
so this move forces atoms to play a very
passive move
is knight to d8
and whenever you can force your opponent
to play passively it tends to work in
your favor
that's at least my experience so after f
takes e5
bishop takes c2 why not f
takes e5 yeah so i mean you could have
played f takes e5 right here right
but again i take back and then the
bishop comes back to e4
and guards the b7 weakness and again i
think your life is very difficult it's
kind of similar to the position we were
looking at before
where i'd say that again even though
maybe you can win it's not so easy
because it's reduced material the bishop
on c6 is very solid
so the idea of rook b8 is to force black
to make a piece worse before you do
anything
so again it's all about these little
subtleties that make make life
a lot more difficult because now black
has to play a passive move
so now after takes takes you have a
similar position except that black has a
knight on d8
and sometimes one passive piece is all
you need
so carlson takes on f6 gf and here finds
a really really nice maneuver
to further weaken black's position and
make it so that it's impossible to hold
on to
all the pawns and hold on to his
position
so once again what is the really really
nice maneuver this is going to be more
than one move by the way guys so i'm not
looking for a
single move suggestion but basically how
do you make it so that black can no
longer hold on to the position
and keep in mind it's probably something
fast if you just bring your king in or
improve some other piece
um most likely black will be able to
play bishop e4 bishop c6 and consolidate
the position somewhat
so you need to be able to do something
very precise
so i see bishop d4 the question after
bishop d4 is what happens so you're
threatening bishop takes f6 check
but what happens if i play f5 there
bishop d2 to a5 is possible but it's
also slow so after bishop d2 for example
i can play bishop a5 and a bishop here i
can simply move away and my bishop
guards to the b7 pawn i put my bishop on
c6 i'd say black has excellent drawing
chances there
so g4 g5 is definitely an interesting
possibility actually
g4 i was considering this because now if
bishop e4 g5 you can't take this pawn
which is kind of annoying
but i might be curious maybe black can
play knight e6 here
so you don't want to take it of course
but
i guess you could play g6 but i might be
able to take that g6 pawn you only have
one pawn left sometimes it's just not
enough
so g4 g5 is possible but again you're
risking liquidating the game a little
bit more i think the way he does it is a
little bit cleaner
so i did see a suggestion for the first
move but again i need more than one move
right
again c6 is possible but i take with the
pawn and i'm not so sure you've actually
helped yourself that much
because again we just have limited
material here when it's limited material
you have to be so precise
because you allow one extra pawn pair of
pawns to trade it often means you can't
win
because again c6 bc rook b6 you might
win one of my pawns but
we've just traded a pair of pawns
trading a pair of pawns doesn't really
help you
so you have to make sure that you try to
keep as many pawns on as possible while
forcing your opponent to
maybe relinquish one of their pawns
basically what i'm saying is win a pawn
for free don't just
trade him
if you exchange the bishop for the
knight i'd say it depends on the
situation right like if i have a really
active rook and a king running up maybe
i can win but
i would say it depends on the situation
so king f3 again is
a decent looking move right you're just
trying to improve your pieces but it's
also a little slow
so for example if i play bishop a4
trying to put my bishop on c6
and here and then maybe bishop c6 for
example so i can move my knight
maybe you have some chances here but i
would also say that black has good
defensive chances once i establish this
kind of setup
so again it's a nice idea but i would
say it's a little bit slow you want to
do something a bit faster
so bishop d4 was played in the game f5
so bishop f6 is definitely a tempting
move trying to simplify the game
but the problem is you still have to
deal with this position after bishop e4
to c6 and again
it's just really annoying the bishop
goes to c6 i just guard everything
and you can try to win this f5 pawn and
maybe that's even winning but i would
say that this is at least challenging
this is not a simple win
and any time you can make your life a
little bit easier because
this you can blow it's very possible not
to win a position like this
so you always want to look for to see if
you have anything better and after
bishop d2 f4
white has a really really nice move
which makes his life a lot easier
and i think free zfx graphics got it
very nice maybe someone else got it also
but the idea is you simply go back so it
looks weird right you play bishop d4 to
provoke the pawn forward
but the idea now is you're threatening
bishop g5 check and there's no real
great solution you don't have time to
play bishop e4 so you have to move your
king
which is what he does but now after
bishop g5 you have to let go of your b7
pawn and this is kind of the crucial
idea
and but it had to be well calculated
because black has knight e6 and again if
you just trade pawns this is not so
clear at all
even if you win a6 and b7 and lose c5
i would say that black has some drawing
chances there because it's such a such
reduced position
but after it takes king c8
the idea here is that if king c6 which
looks like a really annoying move you
have this move rook b6 and this makes
life really really annoying for him
because now if here you have all sorts
of different options even moves like c6
c7 just become possible
uh and i would say that here black's
gonna have some problems at the very
least you can play this
maybe even bishop back and just defend
upon
um but i would say that here it's uh
here black's doing pretty white's doing
pretty well so he chooses to go back to
c8 instead
rook to c2 rook to b2 another precise
move
and again keep in mind he had to
calculate all this before he went into
the sequence it wasn't like he went into
the sequence without seeing this
but the key is he's taking advantage of
this loose bishop on b c2
so the bishop goes back he goes bishop
e7
knight f4
and here the game concluded after rook
a2
king d7 bishop d6
so he grabs this pawn and even though
white only has one pawn left the problem
black has is that this knight on g2 is
completely out of the game
and the pawn on c6 on the c5 if it ever
gets moving is just going to be a deadly
force
so even though this knight even though
it looks like black's really reduced
material just the one pawn and the trap
knight on g2
um really decide the game so it's one of
those things where
it really helps to remember that like
the quality of the pieces matters it's
not just
how many pawns are left or how many
pieces are left the quality of your
pieces matters and i would say that the
knight on g2
even though the materials so reduced the
nano g2 is so bad
that it makes it so that you don't
really have any drawing chances here
so he tries f4 which is understandable
and here carlson finds one last accurate
sequence
and again there might be there's
probably more than one way to win here
so you guys might find something else
but i would say find
his last accurate sequence which enabled
him to win
so i see a bunch of suggestions for
bishop takes f4
this move maybe does it but you have to
be careful because i think after
knight takes which is your move because
if you play
this i think i can play knight e6
and keep in mind if you lose your c pawn
even if you're win a piece back
that's not going to be enough to win
right so you can
you can't take on e4 right away anyway
if you take here this is a drawn king
and pawn end game
which you guys hopefully hopefully know
these
because after you say after this here
here you play king c8 and this isn't
known to be a draw
um and if you play rook a7 check i think
i can just play king up and again i'm
just going to take your pawn so
if you play rook i six check i still
take your pawn if king e4 i play knight
c5
this is this is a way to kind of spoil
all your hard work
so you have to be very careful of doing
this yeah
because it's so easy to you know
think like do all this work you're
thinking i should have a tactical win
here and play bishop takes f4
so i'd say being accurate till the very
last move is just so important
um in all these positions
so i've seen again i've seen the move
but i haven't seen the sequence
so remember don't just suggest one move
suggest a sequence
so again bishop takes f4 i think is not
is not good enough guys
so i see bishop b8 this might be good
enough i mean you're kind of keeping
black really paralyzed
um so a move like bishop e8 probably
would do the trick
uh i don't really see any great solution
rook b6 check grip d6 check maybe is
coming or even rook f6 is very nice and
clean
um so i would say this is good enough
but again you always look at your
forcing moves at four sequences before
you look at moves that are not forcing
sometimes in the end game it's easier to
actually play non-forcing moves and win
that way
but in most cases at least at some point
a forcing variation is what you're going
to need to look for
and a force in variation is what ends
the game here
rook a7 check king c6 rook c7 check king
d5 rookie 7 these are all
very promising ideas i would say though
after something like this
so after here rook here probably does
end the game and i agree with this
because i think that these pieces are
really awkward the king and bishop
but after rook c7 check i might play
king here and this i'm not so sure is
going to be that easy
because now the now bishop can draw back
to c6 and once again i think
you've maybe made life a little harder
than it has to be
so yeah i see avime i think gave this
line um
anvimi oh sorry i'm beaming um you gave
a line with rook a4 here
but again i think i drop back to d5 and
i don't exactly see the win
uh maybe after rick d4 you can you're
still winning here
but i don't know i mean even a move like
f3 looks possible it's at least a little
bit messy still i think
um at least not like 100 clear probably
this should be winning though i would
say
maybe even a zugswong move like this
just forcing me to move
or maybe bishop f8 i don't know
yeah it should be winning uh he chooses
a different way though
so he does start with rook a4 a lot of
you guys are on the money with that one
because it
basically forces the bishop to move to a
certain square um if the bishop were to
move to say b7
then yes i think you can take this pawn
you have to be careful sometimes these
kind of positions are not so easy but
here i think the problem is that the
king is ready to play to
d4 two moves so if like bishop d5 i can
even play like king e3 king d4
and if king here i can play here and
once again king e3 king d4
is just too fast so that should be a
very easy win
if you hang on to your pawn so black
does play bishop c6 here
but the question is what is the key
maneuver now
because taking f4 basically black's
taking away your time so you can't just
take on f4
i don't know about king in the wrong
corner i would say that uh
as long as black has an extra pawn then
sorry as long as white has that c pawn
it should be a win without the c pawn it
should still it should be a draw like
you can't force the king to a8
uh although that would be the wrong
corner yes the bishop would rather be on
the dark squares but i'd say that you
can't force the king to a8
which you'd need to do there with so it
doesn't quite apply
so a lot of you are saying rook a7 check
which is the key
um so if the king has to move to the
back rank i think it's bad news for lots
of reasons and there are probably many
wins uh he chooses to go here instead
and the question is what is the move now
what move forced adams to finally resign
so i see rook d7 but that would hang the
rook so i assume you guys mean rook e7
but after rookie 7 maybe king f6
or king f5 i don't know i think i'm
still playing
so the correct move is rook a6
the idea is that if the bishop moves to
b5 or dc well
bishop b5 or bishop d7 b7 i can play
rook b6 attaining the bishop again
and the main idea is that if the bishop
now moves i can take this pawn with
check
and this should be an extremely easy win
say king here i could even just start
pushing the pawn at some point but just
bishop d6 for instance
or if i want to be really fancy i could
even play bishop b3 because
the bishop is going to be attacked on e4
if takes takes so you don't have time to
take back this pawn this is a fancy way
to do it probably unnecessary but
but the idea is that you take the palm
with checks so it becomes quite easy
and if you defend the bishop of course
you grab it
and take here and this is also a very
easy win so once again
it's mainly winning largely because that
knight on g2 is such a bad piece
um so it's kind of a nice little winning
maneuver but notice how he had lots of
these maneuvers in the game
like he had though like well knight e2
to f4 was kind of the start of it
and then later he had all this um little
fancy stuff
like playing the bishop on d4 delaying
the capture
the rook to b8 move before taking back
the piece
so basically there are lots of
subtleties in these kind of endings and
then finally this side step with the
bishop right where he plays
check and rook a6 um
because it's a four move sequence or
three move sequence right he does this
bishop c6 gives the check and then goes
here
and that uh and that is what ends the
game
so it's one of those where
subtleties make a difference uh when
you're dealing with end games this
complex
right so you want to make sure that you
pay attention and
give these kind of your their full
attention because sometimes one little
accurate sequence can make such a big
difference
um so it's kind of a cool game so i'm
going to move to another one and again
this is a game i've i've
given to students i've lectured on and i
find it to be just a really interesting
exercise again
it really demonstrates the power of the
pieces
in the endgame so let me pull it up
and i believe this should be it let me
just make sure
it yep and i'll flip this one around
because this one is from the black point
of view
and white played the move knight e6
uh hey tyrone so i do i stream myself
um i stream myself
a few times a week usually probably less
now that i'm doing this stuff for the
club
uh and i also give private lessons and
stuff like that
uh and i do have my own youtube channel
actually um
so uh you can uh google me there it's
just josh fidel
um just my name so uh and i'm a private
coach so yeah
i do all that stuff so whatever you were
uh looking for i'm sure it can be
it can be done um
so uh this one is black to move so this
was
um sam shankland uh
2700 player now well maybe a bit under
but you know one of the
main members of the american team and
believe it or not actually a former
student of mine i taught him when i
lived in california maybe
10 plus years ago something like that
about 10 years ago i
uh worked with him when he was about
2200 or so and obviously he uh he became
a lot stronger than me so uh
i'm willing to take credit now he had
lots of coaches i was just one of uh
one of many but uh but it was kind of
cool to see like someone who i've worked
with
uh quite a bit become that strong uh so
he was black in this game against soto
vega
who's a 2350 player from peru i believe
and this was in the
continental championships in 2018 which
he actually went on to win
but he played lots of really great games
in that sequence because i think he won
three tournaments in a row
so i was kind of keeping my eye on him
not just because i knew him but because
usually i like to follow people who are
doing really well at a certain time
because oftentimes you can learn
a lot from their games because they're
really just clicking they're playing
lots of positions well
and this game actually even though it
was um
even though it was kind of against a low
rated player by his standards
it was still just a really striking how
he won this position
seemingly without that much effort
because he's not even up a pawn here
as you guys can see it's like he is an
active king his position looks very
promising
white's king i'd say is really bad but
to win a position like this with
relative ease is actually quite
something
um but again it's all about these little
details
uh have i taught many people who are now
2700 plus no
um i have worked with sam he's
the strongest player who i've worked
with so far uh
and again it was like 10 years ago or so
and i worked with him when he was in the
2200s
um for a little while it was more
informal than formal i'd say but i
definitely uh spent a lot of time
working with him and then
um i'm currently actually working with a
wunder liang who is
a very strong gm but not 2700
um but again it's always nice for me you
know even if students become better than
me it's like a nice
it's a nice feeling you know um but i've
definitely uh
you know worked with my share of very
promising students i've been uh quite
fortunate
so uh okay so this one is black to move
and again this is a very tricky one so
you guys might have to spend a minute or
two because
it's a very complicated position and
you're not finding a win or anything
crushing here
the key is how do you sort out your
position because these knights are just
threatening to check you all over the
place so it looks like such a promising
thing for example just to give you an
example of a bad move do not suggest
this move guys
rook a6 looks like a great move because
you're going to play rook to a1 check
and checkmate the king which by the way
playing for checkmate in the end game
always fun
but you walk into a night fork with
knight c5 check
and this is highly problematic to say
the least
so the key is you have to find a
solution how do you
because you want to attack you really
are playing for an attack here against
white's king
uh and it's something that people forget
you can do in the end game that you can
play for an attack
but you need some way to sort out your
pieces like sort out these night forks
because these knight forks are going to
drive you nuts
so
okay tyrone sounds great actually thank
you very much
so what would you like to do and again i
would say you want to have a specific
idea behind your uh
your approach right like don't just
suggest a move but like what exactly
would your idea be i see a suggestion
for king c4 which makes a lot of sense
because it makes it so that there's not
an e6 can't check you as much
but even here you can run into issues
for example i might be able to try rook
f4
check and then knight check here and
sometimes these kind of things are
annoying because i'm threatening knight
a4 check as well
although even these things are
complicated right because if takes
check here so you can't move your king
because then i give a rook check but
probably you take it
king a3 and the idea is that if i take
this
then you can check here and take this
but then i play this
then i place a knight here and then try
to go after your king side and it's just
a mess right like i honestly have no
idea what's going on here maybe it's
good for you because you have the extra
a pawn
and that was pretty fast right this is
all crazy tactics
and maybe i don't have to play rook at 4
check either
but it's definitely one of the things i
would be slightly worried about at least
i have other moves as well maybe moves
like rook d2 are kind of annoying
um and my main idea is to get the king
out so i would say king c4
is is not a bad move but i would say
that um
it's maybe not not as uh not as precise
as you could be
but honestly king c4 to me looks like a
very reasonable choice
it's just not what he chose
so bishop takes g2 as possible but keep
in mind i don't have to take you back
right
because i can throw in this check and
then the g2 bishop hangs
so you have to be very careful about
moves like this especially when i have
all these checks
ah the ready yeah i mean honestly though
i would say that right now there's
a huge amount of opening stuff out there
uh as far as books as far as lectures
and stuff because
the the fact is that i think most
players who are amateur players who are
trying to improve
spend way too much time on learning and
opening than
and it's it's honestly like for most
people they have to improve at so many
other things they have to learn
more end games they have to become
stronger tactically they have to become
better
middle game players like i would say the
openings are the most
like overstudied part of the game for
most players not for everyone of course
if you don't have a great repertoire if
you're struggling out of the opening
every time probably it's something to
work on but i would say that for most
players
that's kind of overstudied but the
advantage of this is that
there's tons of opening stuff out there
so regardless of what you're looking for
you should be able to find
um plenty of opening stuff out there
like you can always find ways to improve
your openings it's the easiest part of
the game to improve
uh for sure so
type of end game i mean honestly the the
most complex i've seen or certain queen
end games are really hard because
it looks easy but you have so many moves
at your disposal and everything
so many moves deep that calculating it's
almost impossible or at least very
difficult
and there's no alternative to it they're
not intuitive so i would say a lot of
those end games are very tricky
um but honestly any type of end game
like even just rook end games like rook
and pawn against rook
can be really really tough i'd say the
key in the end game is to
assume it's difficult until you kind of
prove otherwise because a lot of people
assume end games are much simpler than
they are
so yeah i mean i i like uh the idea of
um
on view me which is that you want to
trade a pair of pieces because if you
simplify
the black king is going to be stronger
than the white king so i don't mind the
idea of trading a pair of pieces
but you have to determine which piece if
you trade just to do a rook end game
it's unclear that you can win that
easily
um so it's almost like you'd like to
trade one pair of miners but not another
and you also have to make sure to kind
of attack other things
so i would say the way you study the
middle game by the way is you you go
over games like you
see what players are doing you try to
solve positions you try to solve uh
you know complex calculation exercises
things like that um
you learn how to plan there's so many
ways to try to improve
but just the fact is that improving
parts of the game that aren't opening is
just a lot harder
because there's just a lot less out
there it's a lot less a lot more
difficult yeah
no queen end games are absolutely insane
a lot of the time
yeah so knight e4 again the main problem
i have oops i was trying to actually
i was trying to actually move it on
youtube that was pretty hilarious
instead of on my chest base yeah knight
e4 is definitely a tempting move but
again after takes
first of all i also have rook f3 check
moves you have to maybe concern yourself
with but takes
i am assuming maybe bishop takes the
problem is you're actually simplifying
too much i do this i take
here you have chances in this rook end
game but rook end games i'd say
the problem is you can't stop me from
activating my king at some point now and
once i get my king active i think the
win is just going to be really difficult
i can also try to activate my rook maybe
bring it over to a3 to attack your a
pawn
it just becomes really really tricky to
win a position like this you still have
chances of course because you have the
better king
but i'd say that overall it just becomes
really tricky to win
so honestly this is just a really really
um a really really difficult one i
haven't checked out the woodpecker
method yet so i have actually no idea
but a lot of people i know seem to like
it so
um so the move here believe it or not
played in the game was bishop a8
and this is a really really hard move to
find but the main idea is that
the bishop is just always getting forked
and in the way
so you just get out of the way you put
the bishop on aid and say look
the bishop is no longer going to be a
problem
and it's kind of amazing like probably
the best try might be something like
knight c7
but then i can play bishop back to e4
and this knight on c7 is actually just
not a good piece
so we tried knight c5 check and here
once again he should play knight d7 i
think to try to activate this piece
but even here you can play rookie 6
heading for e1
rook check and believe it or not here
you have a super fancy move which is
rookie 4.
the idea being that if you trade and
this is the one advantage though of
having a great king
if you trade off the minor pieces the
rook end game is still going to be tough
but if you trade off the rooks
this king on c4 is just going to walk
and take the b pawn and that a pawn is
going to be nasty knights are horrible
at defending against a pawns
so i see
i see some sarcasm bishop a it's a very
intuitive move yeah it's really really
difficult
but the key thing to realize is that the
bishop is in the way you need it out of
the way
um so knight takes e4 92 check is the
fancy thing and the problem is white has
now is that the g2 and h3 pawns are very
weak and the king is so active on c4
so i would say black has excellent
winning chances here
but white played this move which i think
is just putting a knight on too bad of a
square like the knight on a4 is just
really bad
so sam played rook d6 rook at 4 check
king b3
king f2 g5 the rook went to g4
and this is i'd say one of the few areas
of the game where i think sam misplayed
it i think that he could have played it
a little bit better now
uh he played the move bishop c6
attacking the knight so sam is i'd say a
very concrete player
um so he's always looking for those kind
of forced lines and forced winds which i
think is
in a lot of positions a really good
thing and dude got
due to his 2700 plus at this time so
he was definitely it was working for him
let's put it that way
but i'd say in this particular position
a better method would be to think about
control how do i make it to paralyze
white
rather than thinking um purely about
attacking stuff so what would be a
really great idea to paralyze white and
again this is a
not just one move so you're looking for
a two move sequence here
so rook d2 is possible um but after rook
d2 i think i bring my king
yeah so this actually rook d2 here is a
really interesting move
i think one of my students suggested
this when i was showing this
problem to him and one of the cool ideas
here is that knight e3 believe it or not
walks into knight f1 mate which is
quite nasty um so
i think king e1 is a better try and then
rook takes g2
and probably rook takes g5 i think is
the move but the fact is that you're
reducing material again
so whenever you do that you make it so
that a draw becomes at least
a little bit closer usually so i would
say that while this is still very
promising for black
i i'd say that it's not as clean as you
could be
again you want to think more control
than immediate like
just forcing trying to take stuff think
about how carlson played that last game
he really emphasized
control the moves like bishop d4 just
trying to
put a clamp on his opponent's position
and here i think that if you can control
the knights if you can control the rook
if you can control what black white can
do
you can actually just win very easily
here
very nice uh envy me rook
f6
so king e3 for example rook f5 and this
is
excellent control play because the rook
on g4 has almost no moves the knight on
a4 can no longer go to c5 where it would
cause trouble
and you're just gonna collect g2 and h3
and ask white to resign pretty much
so this is an example of an excellent
kind of prophylactic move
in a very complex position but the idea
is you just guard everything with the
rook on f5
so because you notice how you're
guarding your pawn you're guarding
against the knight
and you're cutting off the king so that
this pawn is just gonna be weak
so the bishop can simply take it just
because the bishop's far away doesn't
mean it can't take it
so rook g4 um so instead he played
bishop c6 which is also a good move but
probably not quite as precise
um here white had the opportunity to
play to sacrifice the b-pawn and play
this and
this looks kind of weird but somehow the
rook and two knights are very
they're kind of a hassle they can harass
the king a little bit and it's not so
easy to win here
but this is not easy to see his opponent
play king e1 which i think is a poor
move
and here sam came up with a really nice
idea which is
he plays king c2 knight c5
um and again this is such a complex
ending um going a little faster than i
intended just
you know again we uh i just want to make
sure that the uh
you know i uh that lecture doesn't go
two hours because believe me you can
look at this game a long time i've
i actually looked at this game with a
wonder um when we were doing a lesson i
gave this position to him and we spent
like an hour and a half easily uh
because it's so complex
but the fact is i just want to kind of
give you an idea of what to look for how
to play these complex positions
so a lot of the times it's about you
have to look for four sequences
sometimes you have to think about
playing kind of more control
um but this is just a really really nice
idea for black so what would you do here
i see a lot of suggestions in the chat
yeah
and this was the idea of playing king c2
by the way
that you're not necessarily just going
eyeing the b2 pawn you're actually
eyeing checkmate
and believe it or not the only way to
prevent checkmate is by sacking the
exchange rook f1 is so powerful
hey dorsa how's it going
uh dorsa by the way if you haven't
missed if you missed her lectures you
definitely shouldn't she uh
gives excellent lectures on here
and you know good friend of mine so
always good to see her anyway
um yeah so rook f6 and the main idea is
you're threatening rook f1
and this checkmate is just going to be
really really tough to deal with um but
again
notice how even though it's an end game
even though
it's fairly reduced you're still playing
for a dynamics you're still playing for
checkmate you're still playing for
tactical ideas
and it's just something that so many
people forget about
um
but yeah hey davina how's it going
uh man all my friends are showing up
just then it's kind of cool
anyway um so rook f1 is is just
unstoppable here
so rook takes g3 was played but now it's
a fairly simple win
white plays knight e2 and here black
simply takes and pushes
which is the easiest way because you're
the a pawn's just gonna make a new queen
or you're gonna have to sack a knight
for it
um so once again i hope you enjoyed
those games there there are two really
really complex positions
uh two really complicated games so if
you didn't see
all the continuations if you didn't
um you know spot everything it's not
such a big deal like
it's really hard and these of course are
very strong players
uh who you're trying to emulate but the
more important thing is to kind of learn
the concepts from this so
when you're playing these complex end
games you have to almost treat them a
little like middle games and that you're
always looking for
you know you still are looking for
attacks you're still looking for tactics
um but at the same time you're often
trying to activate your king you're
often trying to create dangerous pawns
so you still have to treat them like end
games but in a lot of ways they are like
middle games as well
but learning to navigate the dynamics of
these positions is just
always a challenge and always something
that's very interesting so i really
enjoy looking at
end games in positions like this
yo it's josh hi oh my goodness uh
okay um anyway uh thanks so much guys
for
uh watching the lecture i hope you
enjoyed it
let's play it for a 1300 to get better
lots of tactics my friend
lots and lots of tactics and then when
you get sick of tactics
do some more tactics
ah i'm trying to remember honestly i
don't think i read either of those as
far as end games i read something else
so
but it was a long long time ago for me
um
but honestly like yeah uh probably
either of those
is fine it's more important that you
kind of learn the end games
and make sure you go over them and do
stuff like that um
but yeah i mean everyone also has their
own learning style so
makes it tricky anyway guys i hope you
enjoyed it
and i will see you for my next one